and he works on privacy also from the
legal perspective of it and so it should
be interesting to see the follow-up to
what moon just set up for us let's
welcome Maloney thank you
thank
you
um so yeah this I couldn't have asked
for a better setup because I didn't have
to do all the hard work
um I'm explaining everything about
redistricting
um
yeah and I guess just as a as a a very
brief intro this all I got my background
is cryptography and privacy
um and I started I got exposed to this
because Moon and I met at a workshop in
Israel three or four years ago
um and I knew things about differential
privacy and changing things about census
and we sat next to each other at dinner
um and uh then we started talking
um but yeah so so Moon Moon mentioned
that
um when differential privacy uh was
getting adopted by the census
um
there was um worry from civil rights
groups uh there was a bit of a kerfuffle
not just from the civil rights groups uh
so I'm going to tell you a bit about
that kerfuffle
um
uh a kerfuffle is also just one of my
favorite words
um so I'm gonna just start with
it means I don't know I put a definition
in my abstract like a disagreement uh
that stems from different views
if you're is if you speak Hebrew
um
so anyway abstract assistant
one caused by conflicting views right
and the example sentence was uh there
was a kerfuffle over the use of
differential privacy for the 2020 there
you go thanks
all right so that's what a kerfuffle is
so let's start with confidentiality so
the census Act uh uh from 1976 says that
the Census Bureau may not disclose
information reported by or on behalf of
any particular respondent this is the
law that says that the data the census
collects uh has to be kept private it
wasn't always this way I was very
surprised to learn when I uh read more
about this a hundred years ago even less
uh the state was just not uh not kept
private
um so anyway this is what the law says
um and there's there's a basically one
good Supreme Court case that interprets
this law uh and in this case uh there
was a two cities that wanted maybe a
city in a county they wanted access to
the census's address file like where are
houses that's what they wanted
um and uh not counts not population
counts not race and how many people live
in those houses just where are the
houses uh and the court said no the
court the court said even this uh uh the
census has to keep confidential
um
because that law that I just uh showed
you doesn't just require the identity of
the individuals to be confidential it's
any information disclosed by those those
individuals so the the master address
file depends on information disclosed by
individuals so even that had to be held
confidential uh and it didn't matter
what the cities wanted to do with this
it didn't matter that they only wanted
to use it first
and not to you know find people breaking
their leases
uh uh so that's the that's
what the census has to do with the V
confidentiality uh the census as we'll
get to announce that they're going to
use differential privacy as their main
sort of conceptual framework for
disclosure avoidance in 2020.
um
uh and and the main character may be in
the kerfuffo uh one of the main
characters is this guy named Steven
Ruggles and he said well this is silly
um it's based on a misunderstanding of
the law of the confidentiality
requirements he says that to comply with
the law it's not necessary to match the
characteristics of individuals rather
it's necessary to match the identity of
individuals and if you read sort of
everything that uh that Rivals and and
others uh put out it seems like they
would support a view that says let's
make lots of the data just uh public
that would be in compliance with the
confidentiality requirements
um I think it's pretty clear that
Baldridge V Shapiro says no uh not even
the master address file can be made
public let alone the characteristics of
individuals without their identities so
this is this is the uh the
confidentiality sort of debate what is
what other requirements and and did the
old technique satisfy them uh so what
were the old techniques the census uh
used to for 30 years
uh use uh lots of techniques one of them
was swapping uh where they would move
houses uh between blocks based on some
certain characteristics uh of those
houses so if you were like a racial or
ethnic uh uh unique racial or ethnic
house you had a higher chance of getting
swapped and uh they swapped you know the
house that shared some characteristics
and then reported Aggregates based on
that swap data
um uh so that was one of the but not the
only thing that was uh involved in
disclosure avoidance for 30 years
um
and the
that was all well and good
until uh uh the census came out uh and
this is John about he's uh the chief
scientist is was is is he
was replaced by myself
so just John John about uh was the chief
scientist and was really one of the big
forces at the bureau as far as I could
tell so just to be clear I've never been
in the bureau I mean physically I've
been there but I've never been part of
the bureau
um so I don't know anything that is is
is really internal uh but he seemed to
be one of the big forces here
um and so he reports uh originally in a
tweet that the Census Bureau reconstruct
ran a reconstruction attack so let's
look at the published statistics uh uh
come up with some set of a set of
underlying Micro Data that could explain
those statistics that's reconstruction
a consistent set of of census responses
uh and so census ran a reconstruction
attack uh and uh and uh and they they
check the accuracy against their the
data that they have uh and they found
that 46 of the total population uh was
it was exactly reconstructed
um and that sounds really scary
um
and
uh uh
I do want to say that uh uh
this reconstruction attack and when more
information came out about it uh the
more information was sort of received
without much skepticism uh by the
differential privacy academic
differential privacy community
um and I think that was maybe one of the
one of the missteps uh in this kerfuffle
from the from the differential privacy
side uh and Ruggles made a good point
whether a conceptual Point uh uh
conceptual critique uh whether
quantitatively his critique holds water
that's a different question but at least
the conceptual critique is uh you know
how big is this number 46 are we
comparing it to zero are we comparing it
to 35 percent are we comparing it to 40
percent
what's the Baseline here and somehow the
the question that's being asked is
what's the you know what might we be
able to what number can we achieve if
the census didn't output uh uh uh data
and that was a very good conceptual
critique
um and and he made it uh uh in a expert
filing in his expert sort of testimony
um in this out in this lawsuit Alabama
sued the
um the Department of Commerce which is
the Federal agency that under which the
Census Bureau is housed and in that
lawsuit uh Steve Ruggles gave uh his
expert report and in that expert report
uh he makes this critique
um so let's just sort of unpack it a
little bit here's what the census did
they had uh uh they started with people
these this is data collected from 2010
they aggregated and published some of
those data and then they reconstructed
some consistent database D Prime that's
consistent with the published statistics
and they counted the number of matches
they got a number 46 percent
um so Ruggles uh said and I'm taking
this number from a later paper
um ruggle said well if I just sort of
know what types of people exist in the
world and I can sample random people
without looking at the published census
tables
um get some other database D Prime uh
there's supposed to be an arrow here
maybe it'll appear no there's supposed
to be an error here count matches uh and
according to Ruggles you get 41 percent
so we so we can't compare this 46 to
zero we should really be comparing it to
41.
um that's sort of the content conceptual
content of the community
where does this where does this original
data come from
to get the 41 like what are they using
this data here
oh okay that's what you yeah yeah are
you asking or is it did I answer the
question are you I'm asking where this
I'm asking like like where does it come
from in the world because I would think
of like where else right so it also
comes from census Publications exactly
so there's a there are like there are
like many conceptual and quantitative
problems with this critique uh but it's
still sort of a something that that has
to be wrestled with uh I I would say
um I don't want to get into it
um uh as as you'll see in this talk I'm
going to touch on a lot of things and
not get into any of them
um
but uh but even if you don't really get
into this so so the point Rachel is
making is this data itself comes from
census data so if census Publications
have always been disclosive uh and
you're trying now to say that the census
Publications are disclosive it's sort of
unkosher to use a census publication and
say that if I just have this data then I
can basically get the same accuracy as I
can get from this data and therefore
this data is not disclosive right you're
assuming that this data is not
disclosive but if Census Data had a
disclosure problem then since this data
may have had a disclosure problem here
and here it's it's a there's a uh
epistemic like problem here uh okay but
anyway I don't I don't even want to get
into that
um so so X Ruggles expert filing came
three days before the deadline for
amethyst briefs and there were a bunch
of DP people uh writing and amicus
briefs uh in support of the census's use
of differential privacy and so we had a
few days to scramble to figure out uh
how to respond to sense to a regular's
critique uh and so one thing we figured
out is
um so this comes from uh the census's
Reconstruction experiment where they
break down the Reconstruction rate
that's 46 percent uh by these number of
people within a census block so the re
the the the rate of reconstruction is 46
number for blocks with zero to nine
people in them was something like uh 23
it's not clear this is all the
information we have so you can eyeball
it
um uh and for blocks with very many
people it's you know 60-ish percent
if you rerun what Ruggles uh did
and you break it down by block then you
get something that looks like this that
on on Big Blocks ruggles's method works
very very well
uh but on very small blocks ruggles's
method works very poorly and if you want
to understand why this is you know let's
say you're playing cards and your
opponent has a 20 card hand you can
guess a lot of the cards in their hand
just by chance and if you're playing
hold them and your opponent has two
cards in their hands it's very hard to
guess something in their hands and
that's sort of that's what's going on
here yeah go ahead
literal census blocks right these are
literal census blocks but but then
there's also okay I'll just
later but the the big ones are usually
group quarters are usually like prisons
and dorms and so those are also special
or like a high-rise
yeah yeah so those are also special
right those aren't just big
they also are special in other ways I'm
sure that's true yeah
um um yeah I I'm I'm doing something
very coursier you're saying you could do
better on such blocks because you know
things about them yeah uh this the the
the the the argument that was being
levied here was a very simple argument
and therefore like one should contend
with it
um
uh but the I think the deeper Point
you're making is there's a lot more
information uh that one could use both
here and here frankly right if you're
trying to show that these Publications
were disclosive you can make use of
other plenty of other information this
reconstruction step the thing the census
did was very just completely oblivious
find some Micro Data that was consistent
with the underlying Publications in fact
uh there's a paper posted an archived as
I think yesterday
by I don't know Cynthia dork Aaron Roth
Michael Kearns and maybe four other
people uh
um they basically say hey let's put a
bunch of other information into this
step uh and see how well this uh see how
well we can do I haven't read the paper
but I think they say that you can do
very well very very much better than uh
than this sort of 46 I'm not exactly
sure what that paper says because it
literally came out last night
um
yeah so for the hurricane
for the argument of Ruggles did he say
like assume this minimum block size just
reported this aggregate
in his expert testimony not this number
but this comes from the later paper
which is you know the weighted average
weighted by a a number of blocks of
these populations of these red bars
right uh but the point here is that uh
the Reconstruction Works uh you know
pretty well for small blocks where this
sort of random oblivious thing doesn't
work at all for small blocks and Alabama
was the stated issue in the lawsuit I
don't remember exactly but some
I don't know maybe it was 20 of blocks
uh or 50 people or less uh some some
large large fraction of blocks in
Alabama
um
so
in any case uh the census announced that
they're going to use differential
privacy uh uh as their sort of
conceptual framework for the 2020 census
uh if I say anything wrong just jump in
all right
um so what's differential privacy it was
defined yesterday uh basically it's a a
a a a definition that says an algorithm
is differentially private if when you
run uh this algorithm on on a data set
or a data set with one person's
information removed or changed the
output is basically the same I'm not
going to get into details they're not
going to matter for the stock
um
um so the census uh uh wants to use
differential privacy they have to build
an algorithm I'm sure Phil will tell you
all about that and how uh what went into
the making of that algorithm
um I'm gonna say very little but how
does this algorithm the top-down
algorithm work they take the uh data the
census enumerated uh data they add some
noise
to that data and then they uh they post
process to make the the resulting data
sort of nice so make the resulting
counts non-negative
make them all consistent
make them integers satisfy various uh
invariants and constraints and then you
do this for the State national level and
you do it for the state level you make
sure that these counts are consistent
with these counts and you do this down
the census hierarchy that Moon mentioned
and you get down to the Block Level and
then you at the end of this this
top-down algorithm is why it's called
that
you have a noisy Micro Data we have you
have sort of synthetic microdata that
that is consistent with uh sort of many
of these noisy statistics as close to
these noisy statistics
um so I just want to look at an example
and this is everything I'm going to say
about uh top down so here's an example
this is uh the enumerated counts this is
the input to the top down algorithm uh
Now sort of at the Block Level we've
imagined that we've done the nation the
state the trade county is the tracks the
block groups so we're at the Block Level
uh and let's just look at for example
the population under the age of 18. uh
so in this block uh block one there's 25
people
uh how much noise is added uh to these
counts you sample this from an
appropriate probability distribution so
some of the noise is zero some of the
noise is positive some of the noise is
negative you add these numbers and these
numbers you get noisy counts right
um some of these noisy counts now we'll
notice are negative which is that's
weird
uh because it's like negative one people
live in this block
um and so and then there's this
post-processing step and the
post-processing step uh for the purposes
of the intuition I want to build for you
help you build now does two important
things one is it makes counts
non-negative
uh so here you can see that this minus
one got pushed up to zero
um and the other thing is is it makes
the counts uh consistent with the the
accounts from the higher level and the
hierarchy so all these counts are sort
of uh changed so that the noisy
populations in the blocks add up to the
noisy population in the block group that
was computed in the previous step if
iterative algorithm
um so that's sort of how it works well
it's much more complicated than that but
that's some good intuition for it
um and the noise here at least at like
scales you know bigger than blocks or in
places that are not extremely sparse
uh the noise is uh is pretty small uh so
these are uh these are all counties all
of this is counties and so this is uh uh
some from some census publication here
it is
um which tells you uh the uh sort of the
scale of the noise middle 90 of the
noise for County populations that came
from top down and you can see it's sort
of in the single digits of people right
this is like in units of people
uh uh um
quite small and here are some other
sources of census estimates as to other
sources of noise
um and sort of the middle 90 is in the
hundreds or thousands
um
and even the mean uh the mean magnitude
is in the hundreds
so it's sort of completely different
scales
um
right so as Moon mentioned yesterday
um there was a there was an outcry for
many data users and some people said
that this was uh what did you say I had
I had the quote written down but I think
I deleted it we have to destroy the data
in order to save the data uh um was one
person's take
great so so what did this look like
again a lot of this sort of happened on
Twitter
um uh Ruggles uh posted tweet I'm
increasingly convinced that DP will
degrade the quality of the Census Data
available about the population will make
scientifically useful public use
microdata impossible I do want to say
that I'm going to try to be careful
sometimes I mess up I'm going to try to
say the top-down algorithm because the
top-down algorithm in differential
privacy are different types of things
the different categories of things
um but if I say DPA I say it um but what
we're thinking about is is the top-down
algorithm
specific as a specific instantiation of
a DP style approach
any case
so what's the sort of the question here
uh the question is I think the big
question so here's this sort of whole
pipeline a cartoon whole pipeline from
there are people in the world to uh uh
moon is going to address some maps
um right so what happens is there's
population that data is collected
um consensus sends you mail and sends
people to knock on your door so there
are responses that data is then clean
and the result of that is the census
edited file that census edited file goes
through this disclosure avoidance this
is the top-down steps the differential
private step what used to be swapping
the result of that is is the result of
that it's called the microdata file
um and then there's some stuff that the
census does internally with this data
they produce data products and then
those data products are used by people
outside to you know learn about the
world and describe the world and then
make decisions
and what we really care about I I I'll
I'll pause it is you want to know how
design decisions here affect the policy
outcomes here
that sort of ultimately
uh if you only care about one thing
maybe that's the thing you care about
at least that's the thing I care about
if I only care about one thing and so
what's an example can I get yeah
do the do the ruggleses of the world
also only care about policy outcomes or
do they care about things like
statistics as well
um I think uh so I think the I don't
want to uh say uh what other people
care about
um I I do think the the
in the same way that Christina yesterday
said that they you know the ad Tech
marketing managers don't know what to do
with like they're used to having certain
data uh and they're used to using it and
they're not used to thinking about that
data is not statistically valid uh uh
it's the that's the same
that also describes sort of census data
users and I do want to be very clear
that some users of census data are
sophisticated
uh statistically sophisticated and some
users of census data aren't but should
be
uh but some are not and sort of
shouldn't be uh so I had a conversation
with the guy who's the demographer for
the city of Cambridge and what is the
demographer of the city of Cambridge
care about he cares about a renovating
playgrounds because he wants to know
where the kids like where are their what
are the neighborhoods that are having
kids and have young families so that
those playgrounds can get budgeted a
million dollars to get a new playground
there five years from now right I don't
want him to know about the French of
privacy frankly right like his life is
complicated enough he is caring he cares
about elder care and handicap ramps and
playgrounds
um
and so that guy you know like has a very
valid you know uh Grumble
uh and and he shouldn't have to know
about you know P tests and confidence
intervals and
I don't know
maybe that's an opinion you can disagree
um okay so I I claim that this is the
question uh um and so just some examples
um
um the one data product and the data
product I'll talk mostly about is the
redistricting data this is all the data
that uh moon was using
um another example which I'll mention
very briefly is something called a small
area income in poverty estimates
basically like how much money are
certain small neighborhoods and areas
and rural areas uh uh making
and these uh estimates this is a census
data product
uh uh
um they directly go are fed into a
formula and that formula goes to
allocate billions of dollars over years
maybe it's hundreds of millions of
dollars I think it's billions
um under Title One funding and then
eventually all this data also goes to
inform the design uh and execution of of
later census sort of data collection and
processing efforts so something uh like
the American Community surveys my
understanding uh is that the some of the
sampling design and the post uh survey
stratification and stuff is informed by
the 2020 census data
uh and and and all of this data goes on
to inform basically all of social
science and all of policy making
um and
what I want to and and so the challenge
here if if that's what we want to study
you know from here to here
um the challenge is that all of this is
sort of for people outside the bureau
all of this is pretty unknown
right exactly how this cleaning happens
it's not really known we don't have
access to this data set at all right
this is the thing that has to be kept
confidential we don't have access to our
responses these are unknown things
makes it hard to study
um it's also hard uh challenging because
the disclosure avoidance algorithm the
the top-down one is really complicated
so there's papers that describe it
there's a Code base
um it turns out actually getting that
code base to run on any data uh it's
pretty challenging uh and so I've tried
item not the coder myself but I've
worked with people who've tried uh I had
students try
um they managed to get at work like a
couple times but then you know there's
uh configuration errors on the Amazon
ec2 instance and they're completely
mysterious and it's very hard to
actually like get to get this to run a
hundred times or a thousand times in
order to do statistics right because
what you really want to do is you just
take the data set you run this algorithm
a thousand times and you learn about
what it does right and then carry out
this whole pipeline uh um but we don't
have the input data it's very hard to
sort of run uh uh the top-down algorithm
and it's complicated enough that it's
hard to just think about it from a
theoretical point of view
um and also these internal analyzes are
often inscrutable at least for me I've
tried very hard to understand how the
small area income and poverty estimates
are made
um and as far as I can tell there's just
it's it's a it's a complete
would you call it a mathematical Thicket
it's a policy Thicket I just it could
not access it
um at all
um this is not true for the
redistricting data the reducing data is
a simple aggregation of certain of of
certain data so we do know how uh one of
these is made
but it makes it very difficult to study
this uh you know this the question which
is how does the design of the disclosure
avoidance algorithm affect Downstream
policy making right we don't know what
to input and we don't know what happens
with the output and we don't quite
understand what's happening in the
middle
um so now I'm going to tell you about
some attempts at doing this uh this is
what I call the Quagmire
um
um it's both a methodological Quagmire
because you have to figure out how to
deal with these problems and I think
that if you're looking for a problem
like if you're looking for a research
question in my talk uh uh the the
research question is sort of how to
navigate The Quagmire I'm I'm going to
give you a few options that I've seen in
in work I think there's Theory and
empirical questions here
it's also sort of a rhetorical Quagmire
where people with uh different goals are
are trying to uh uh ask questions and
present their findings in ways that
further their own agendas
um and so let's Journey Through The
Quagmire
um so one option if you're going to try
to solve sort of the methodological
problem is to just be the Census Bureau
not all of us have this option
um but it's great uh you know so this is
from a paper I don't particularly care
what this table is showing but the point
is they can do this they can do uh run
25 runs of the top-down algorithm on
some input data and reports um some
empirical variants over all the runs and
you can learn things like that but only
the census can do that as far as I can
figure out
um
cool so that's one option
um another option is to is to have uh
have like read the papers and try to
just understand what the algorithm is
doing uh and and so here's a wrong but
useful model uh for how to think about
what top-down algorithm does
um which is going to help explain some
of what we're going to see soon
um so noise is added uh to block to
sorry to Geographic units counties
tracks blocks and this noise is you know
roughly gaussian
um where this parameter row depends on
the Geo unit and uh the statistic that
you're interested in
uh and then as I said before you post
process this to make sure the accounts
are not negative and they sort of add up
to consistent uh consistent and this
sort of top-down way and so what
non-negativity gives you is that small
accounts you know if they go negative
they have to be pushed back to zero and
so the error added to small counts is
biased positively and when you combine
that with consistency in a place where
there are small counts like if you're
looking at uh blocks within a block
group and some of those blocks are very
sparsely populated then the very
populist blocks uh those large counts
are going to get by it's negative
because they sort of have to compensate
for the small for the small counts
uh so this is like uh useful but wrong
mental model and it's it's actually it's
actually I was very surprised by the
following I tried to understand how how
good was this was this description uh at
least the first line uh so if you if you
figure out if you go to Wikipedia and
you look up what's the expected
magnitude of a gaussian random variable
because I had to go to Wikipedia uh you
get that it's uh this expression and
then you could look at tables like this
that the census has put out about how
the Privacy budget this row was sort of
allocated across different levels of
geographies and different queries and so
you can look you would say the row for
the total population statistic at the
county level you just look up this in
the table you get a value of 0.213 you
plug it into this expression you get
that your expected uh magnitude of error
is 1.73
right you do the same thing for a track
and you get 1.97 and then you could look
at uh some examples census data that
puts out the they've put some example
the demonstration data which I'll talk
about in a second they put out and
compute this average across every County
in the country of the error and you get
1.74 which is remarkably close
uh you could do the same thing for a
track and you get 1.92 which is also I
would say pretty remarkably close for
such a really bad mental model
um useful and so I think if you force me
to say it seems useful from what from
what little I've played with it it seems
useful when you're looking at
uh the sorts of geographies uh where
these small counts don't uh come into
play that much and when you're looking
at statistics simple statistics like
total population 10 minutes okay cool
um okay so that's option uh another
option just sort of try to reason and
build some intuition for what's going on
um option two
um is use the demonstration data most of
the work studying the effects of the
top-down algorithm has been of this type
uh where they've looked at the
demonstration data what's the
demonstration data well we have the real
data that was published the published
data uh from 2010 so there's the 2010
data I went through the 2010 disclosure
system 2010 MDF 2010 aggregations right
that has been public for 12 years
uh the census uh in order to try to get
feedback on on the new disclosure voting
system said well let's put the same data
through the 2020 disclosure avoidance
system
and published demonstration 2010 data as
if that data had been privatized uh uh
using top down instead of swapping right
um and so you can look at these two data
sets right that's what I did on the last
slide that was down here
um and so what you can do is you can
sort of look at these two data sets and
compute some descriptive statistics
um that's sort of what I did just a
second ago I do want to caution you that
you learn about the difference between
this disclosure avoidance system and
this disclosure avoidance system right
you can't access just the effects of
this only the difference between this
and this
uh and you can also redo prior analyzes
and say okay we we use this data for 10
years and we did lots of stuff with it
let's redo that stuff and compare the
results of that those analyzes with this
data and with this data and see what
changes
um and the in the the caution here is uh
you learn sort of about uh the effect of
changing your data adding noise to data
which could be uh you know you could say
that that's the effect of the disclosure
avoidance system you could also say that
that's the effect of a very brittle
statistical analysis and so we'll see
some of that in a second
um so if you look at the demo data uh
you see this bias from non-negativity
which I I hinted a few minutes ago so
this is from some old demo data this is
from some newer demo data this is two
different papers a couple years apart
and they basically say here don't worry
about what exactly is on the x-axis on
the left is a racially heterogeneous
places places with a lot of uh different
populations represented different racial
and ethnic groups represented and on the
right is places with basically One race
uh in that in that in that I think
precincts here and I don't remember what
these are
tracks they're like enumeration
something there's some word in 1940s but
they're tracks
yeah
um and what you see is exactly this
thing that uh when you have uh uh
there's this correlation where uh where
you have the small counts here I see
small counts are biased upwards here so
what are the small counts they're the
empty cells in that uh say Precinct
population uh so if that precincts
population is like the white population
the black population the non-white
Hispanic population the Asian American
population
if you're on the right side of this
picture most of those are zero and those
counts get biased upwards so the total
uh the total gets biased upwards and if
you're in the left they're all sort of
far from zero uh and to compensate those
things have to get by itself so that's
exactly what we're seeing what's my
understanding of what we're seeing here
um
you can rerun uh uh you know uh past
analyzes so so this is from a paper and
they say well the top-down algorithm is
going to destroy our understanding of of
mortality rates from covid right so what
do they do they look at uh uh um they
take a County's population they also
take uh broken down by race and
ethnicity so here's the non-hispanic
population of a County
uh they take the mortality rate for that
group uh from covid let's say in 2025 or
so uh and in in some month in 2020 they
divide the two numbers
and they compare that and now the
difference of the of the mortality rate
with the published data and the noisy
data
um the noise the demonstration data and
they say look you know for a small
population counties the our
understanding of mortality rates is like
wildly different right
um uh so they find that the
implementation of differential privacy
will produce dramatic changes in
population for aspirational and ethnic
minorities small areas
significantly altering our knowledge
about health disparities
um but I claim that this is a this is a
story about brutalness to noise and so
uh here's another plot that I made
myself uh where you just take X
uh you see you you take some number X
you plot log X on the x-axis which is
what they did you plot a uniform noise
from -30 to plus 30 over divided by X
which is sort of if you figure out
what's going on here that's exactly
what's going on it's sort of this is the
noise
uh the difference between the two data
sets divided by the population uh so
what this tells you is that this
analysis whatever they're doing is is
you know highly affected by noise on the
scale of 30 people so if if let me
translate that your what they're saying
is your understanding of the
non-hispanic black mortality rate from
kovid in counties with a very small
black populations is extremely brittle
to noise on the order of 30 people
um
all right so I so I think like the wrong
lesson was derived uh or this was
wielded to the wrong wrong ends uh I
have another example I'm not going to
tell you about
um so a third option if you're trying to
do the mythological
Quagmire is to try to run top down
anyway just do your best uh and so this
uh is something that Moon and I did with
uh some students
um where we used we couldn't get the
real data so we tried to reconstruct uh
Census Data ourselves we couldn't uh we
didn't have access to the the production
version of top down it wasn't public yet
we used an old version of top down we
were able to get running uh somewhat and
we used sort of a simplified uh model
based on papers and this and the not not
uh good but wrong but useful model
uh we ran these things many times and
were able to derive statistics and and
do the sort of studies uh that we wanted
to do
um
so here's an example uh and and I'm
totally gonna run out of time so I think
I'm Gonna Leave the lawsuit I was going
to tell you all about the lawsuit
um but I want to tell you this instead
um so one of these analyzes that uh uh
uh Moon mentioned uh was this Jingles
tests part two and three you run uh
fairly standard statistical package so
here's one of the things you you can do
uh or you you do in those analyzes it
amounts to a linear regression uh where
on the x-axis you have the Hispanic
population where each of these now I
think is a Precinct
it's a Precinct
um and on the y-axis you have that
Precinct the share of that Precinct that
voted for a certain candidate so this is
a a certain race in Dallas County for
Texas governor uh where the candidate
was Lupe Valdez and so it's the uh this
dot has 60 Hispanic population that's
Precinct and 40 of that Precinct voted
for Lupe Valdez
um and this y-intercept uh represents
under this method this method called
ecological regression is interpreted as
the Hispanic support for this candidate
Lupe Valdez
um now as Moon alluded to uh you can
worry that if you add noise to the
census counts in particular you're
adding noise
in this direction on the Hispanic
population you're going to add noise to
this signal and in particular you're
going to attenuate it usually
um
uh and and so what can we still detect
racially polarized voting
um
and so in our paper we sort of uh looked
at this effect uh
and and showed that indeed you know it
looks like a there's a bunch of noise if
you just do the the the old thing but
you can do very simple things in order
to sort of recover the the the previous
uh the previous sort of uh robust
version in particular if you just ignore
precincts with small numbers of votes uh
24 of precincts in this case
um then you would cover sort of the
noiseless linear regression you don't
have to just ignore those precincts you
can do weighted uh weighted linear
regression that's sort of maybe the more
uh disciplined thing
um so you can see sort of the effect of
these precincts here which is sort of
all noise and just as noising this
regressor is removed here but you can do
weighted linear regression instead and
when you're in Dallas it's not such a
big deal maybe uh when you're somewhere
much smaller this is Brazoria County the
noise uh from top down if you're sort of
ignoring it and running previous
analyzes unthinkingly
um is significant uh but if you do sort
of anything reasonable uh that noise is
no longer significant
um I'm gonna skip this I'm gonna just
point out again that in this paper uh
which is about the title one funding
issue they again this is a rhetorical
thing more than anything they uh they
highlight sort of the effect of of noise
on their analysis is in the tens of
Millions
um but when you compare that to other
sources of noise that are Quantified and
estimated by the census
it's a drop in the bucket and when you
compare it to the total amount of
funding
uh it's even sort of a smaller drop in
the bucket
um
um so yeah I don't know this is a this
is a maybe a lesson in in ways of
communicating and what to what ends
um how much time do I have no minutes
all right so suffice it to say that
there was a lawsuit that I wanted to
tell you about
um where the census was releasing
purposely blood population tabulations
uh uh which is a fun uh way of uh
describing it and the outcome at the end
of the day there's lots of interesting
questions which I'm happy to talk about
um the outcome at the end of the day had
nothing to do with differential privacy
and had everything to do with uh just
sort of basic 1l uh points of law in
particular Alabama had no standing to
Sue and the reasoning the Court's
reasoning to say that they had no
standing to sue for like each of these
points it's actually very interesting
um again I'm happy to talk about it
um
so future directions we need more work
uh there's a lot of empirical and Theory
work
um and Phil will also tell you Philip
will also tell you lots of other things
that you can do to help and to
contribute
hey let's thank aloni
[Applause]
we have time for one question while um
should she sets up for the post to
presentation announcements
anyone have a question
oh this is a pretty general question
well thanks for the talk really enjoyed
it
um it seems like a meta level thing that
is going on is a lot of reproducibility
um and I'm wondering if through like
build uh building toy down if there's
any lessons on reproducibility or best
practices that are
clean from this process
I
think that
that's a good question I agree that
reproducibility is is a part of what
makes studying it really difficult it's
challenging to think
about how you might
provide you
the Census Bureau might provide
reproducibility
um
in a setting where your your hands are
tied by stringent confidentiality
requirements in particular the data
can't be known
the input data can't be known that's the
whole point
um
could do better about having a easier to
run top-down algorithm
um but still that's
um
that's only part of the story and the
other part of it is just the there's a
thousand ways that this there's more
than a thousand ways that the data
ultimately gets used either internally
at the bureau or externally by social
scientists or economists or basically
every paper empirical paper uses this
data in one way or another
um
and sort of I think you would have to
solve the reproducibility issue for all
of those Works in order to understand
really the downstream effects
thank you so much uh so uh without
taking too much time into our next break
I want to give a very brief overview
preview of the posters we have uh this
afternoon so please come to the poster
session it's at four to five pm on the
second floor and we'll have tea just
before uh the session at the same SP in
the same space so everyone's welcome to
come so what we'll do is we'll do a
quick run through all the posters that
are going to be presented and when your
name shows up uh the student in the
audience please just stand up introduce
yourself introduce the title of your
poster really quickly in like 15 to 20
seconds we'll see how
and this is in Reverse alphabetical
order by last name just to keep you all
on your toes so here we go so uh
uh
no oh uh hello everyone my name is I'm
from uh UIUC and the work I'm presenting
is called personalized parting with
group fairness constraint it's a joint
work with Professor Xin chin uh from
Georgia Tech and you enjoy from
Singapore University uh welcome everyone
to attend my poster session this
afternoon thank you
thank you uh Anna
foreign
link analysis ranking mostly related to
web search applications this is work
done partially with my advisor from
Colombia Agustin Chan throw and
partially here at Simon's with uh I mean
severity too some of it is still ongoing
so we very much welcome feedback thank
you
thanks roshni
hi everyone my name is roshni and I'm a
third year computer science PhD student
at Stanford my research focuses on
developing statistical Frameworks for
data-driven decision making and the
poster I'm presenting today is called
learning from a biosample and this is
Joint work with Lee Holly and Stephon
Walker at Stanford
thanks uh Fernando
hi everyone I'm uh Fernando Rodriguez
from Stamford doso and Zuni
um they're both representing is
improving organizational decision making
non-profit organizations uh using a
decision analysis framework
uh it's uh that the authors are real
structure at
also from Stanford
thanks uh Young
everyone I'm saying from Columbia
University I'm a third year PhD student
compute in computer science department
um the poster that I'm going to present
today is about differentially private
synthetic control as the name can tell
like uh it's synthetic control is a
causal inference method and we made it
differentially private thanks
Juan
hi everyone uh so I'll be talking about
work in performative prediction and new
solution Concepts and product prediction
this is together with Mike Kim who's
here at Simon's
thanks uh George
everyone uh I'm George norov I'm PhD
student at UPenn and today uh my poster
will be about
um how to categorize
um
scoring rules not just according to you
know if they're proper or not we should
incentivize is stressfulness uh but also
to what extent do they incentivize the
reporting of precise estimates so we
encourage the experts to perform a lot
of sampling from the underlying
distribution
you know what scoring rules are good for
that
foreign
I'm David and this is Joint work with
Priyanka who's also here
um this paper is a little bit different
we basically read a bunch of the nerups
ethics reviews and broader impact
statements and then summarized what we
found so come learn about that
it's uh Yuan Tong
UE hello everyone my name is Juan Tony
from UCLA Department of statistics and
today I would like to
represent the read album contextual
online matching mandates with our
application into the job market
thanks Chiang wai
hi everyone I'm an assistant in
operations management from Duke
University I'm going to present the
poster titled blockchain news vendor
value of freshness transparency and
smart contracts it's mainly about
blockchain applications in fresh reduce
industry to reduce food waste this is
Joint work with my devices boil
engineered
thanks uh devunch
hi everyone I'm devunch I'm also at
Stanford and the paper I'll be
presenting will be on balancing
efficiency and fairness in traffic
routing and so this is essentially
looking at the problem of routing road
traffic from a perspective of not only
achieving system efficiency that is
trying to reduce traffic congestion but
also achieving certain fairness
properties in the process as well
Andrew
is not here uh evangelia
hi everyone I'm evangelia and I'm a
fifth year PhD student at University of
Wisconsin Madison
so my poster will be about uh online
learning for Pandora's Box and means
Sunset cover basically it's a follow-up
on some other work we have with student
my advisor Christo James
thanks uh Bailey
foreign
hi my name is Bailey I'm a PhD student
at Carnegie Mellon and I'll be talking
about work that's joined with Ariel
precautions Fenway
um basically we generalize the standard
model of voting to allow voters to
behave altruistically uh which means
that they account for the common good
and how they vote let me show that this
can have really positive impacts on the
outcomes of Elections
thanks uh Kate
um okay don't do I'm a PhD student at
Cornell and I'll be talking about models
of fairness and Federated learning which
is joint work with my advisor John
kleinberg
um we look at sort of Federated learning
so agents that have data that's
distributed among multiple different
locations and they're each trying to use
this data sort of to build a model that
has high performance on their own
personal data set in collaboration with
other agents we look at questions of
fairness meaning like differential
levels of error rates that these
different agents
thanks mahila
[Music]
hi everyone my name is
and I'm a fourth year graduate student
at Berkeley broadly my research is on
understanding dynamics of interaction
between algorithmic decision makers and
human decision makers in this work we're
looking at the impacts of Link
recommendations and social networks
particularly showcasing how they might
have unexpected effects when measured
um in a delayed time frame and how they
can have indirect effects that are very
unexpected with respect to
the short-term immediate effects
thanks Andre
hi um I'm Andres Christi I'm a 58th PhD
student at University Chile in this work
we ask how to make Fair decisions if we
are hiring people sequentially like in
the secretary problem
um I hope to see you at the positive
daily Mark about it
thanks uh Sarah
hi my name is Sarah San and I'm a fifth
year PhD student at MIT and I'm really
talking today on regulating algorithmic
filtering and social media where
algorithmic filtering is the process
used to curate content and it's going to
be a sort of Regulation and auditing
framework this is Joint work with my
co-advisor is Alexander Madre and David
Bradshaw
thank you William
I am William I'm a PhD student at
Columbia I'm presenting some work on a
model for studying feedback loops and
recommendation systems particularly when
you're showing users menus of items and
looking at what sorts of regret
benchmarks are feasible what assumptions
you need and connections to diversity
recommendations
let's joined with arpit who's also been
around this semester
thanks Robin
hello I'm Robin Bowers I'm a second year
PhD student at the University of
Colorado Boulder I'm presenting joint
work with my advisor Beau Wagner called
high rope for a matching markets via
descending price which is sort of an
auction inspired spin on matching
markets with money
hey and that brings us to the end of
this session thank you very much please
do come to the poster session this
afternoon and we have a short break
outside we will get back here for
Phillips talk uh a little past 11 30 and
please also use the opportunity to ask
Moon and aloni any questions that God
left thank you
[Applause]